It's been Huda's dream to open a salon that caters to women in her community.
As soon as you walk in to many salons, it's an open space,...
...but here, it's designed to be a beauty safe haven.
It will have a small reception area,...
...where men are welcome to wait for the woman in their life.
But beyond these doors, no guys allowed,...
...no male customers, no male employees.
They can take their scarf off and they can just feel at ease as if they're at home...
...and get any service that they need done.
It's a sprawling interior with a bridal boutique in the basement that she designed herself.
You can get your haircut, nails or makeup done....
...and receive skincare treatment among other services.
It's an amazing feeling to be not only a salon owner...
...and not only a Muslim salon owner, but a Yemeni woman in business...
...because it's a little bit more difficult in our culture...
...to be able to open up a business as a woman on your own.